[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité au sommaire de ce
journal après les Pays-Bas et la
Belgique l'année dernière c'est
maintenant en Allemagne et en France que
les agriculteurs manifestent leur ex
expération par des actions
spectaculaires le ralbol et la
mobilisation des agriculteurs cé temps
en France nous y reviendrons en détail
avec nos partenaires TL7 et via
occcitanie sur le Bassin d'Arcachon nous
irons avec TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest à la rencontre de ces pêcheurs
eux aussi en colère ils sont plus de 500
entre le pays- basque et le finisterè à
être immobilisé afin de protéger les
dauphins présents sur nos côtes avec
notre partenaire o TV la chaîne de la
voie du Nord nous nous rendrons dans la
Somme afin de tirer les premiers
enseignements de la décision de la
commune de flixcour qui propose
désormais sa cantine à 1 € afin de
contrecarrer les effets de l'inflation
enfin nous irons découvrir ce sport
récent issu de multiples arts martiaux
le MMA depuis son autorisation en France
le succès du MMA ne se dément pas au
point que certains clubs mettent en
place des cours spécifiques c'est ce que
nous verrons avec via
ooccitan nous commençons ce journal avec
les agriculteurs malgré les premiers
échanges avec le Premier ministre leur
colère prend de l'ampleur toute la
semaine ils se sont mobilisés dans
plusieurs départements d'Occitanie
d'abord la hautegaron puis le tarnégaron
le Gers ou encore les Pyrénées
Orientales le monde rural attend
désormais des actions concrètes du
gouvernement regardez ce reportage de
Lisa Hervé pour via
[Musique]
Occitanie la reconstruction d'un mur de
paille symbole de de la résistance
agricole voilà 4 jours que les
agriculteurs auugaronais occupent la 64
dans les deux sens chaque jour il se
relaent le soir ils sont 400 à se
rassembler la nuit une dizaine d'entre
eux dortent ici dans cette ben à céréal
et ce n'est pas prêt de s'arrêter c'est
les trois au riens c'est le GNR le
gasoil non routier c'est l'irrigation
sans eau pas d'agriculture et après bien
sûr il y a des r des mesures locales qui
sont pour nous la MHE la maladie
hémorragique épisotique qui touche nos
chtel c'est qu'on a des pertes
considérables c'est la fin de nos
exploitations des petites exploitations
de
campagne un mouvement suivi par des
agriculteurs éleveurs et viticulteurs
dans d'autres départements le Tarn Garon
le Gers l'Ariège ou encore les pirénés
oriental devant le péage sud de
Perpignan une soixantaine de tracteurs
ben
rempli mobilisation forte dans ce
département particulièrement touché par
la sécheresse on avait une très petite
récolte et le problème problème qu'il y
a et derrière ça on a eu en plus la grê
dessus qui est tombé et le gros problème
c'est qu' il n'a pas Blu ça fait plus
deun an et demi qu' en a pas d'eau et
donc s'il ne pleut pas même sil ple je
sais même pas la récolte qu'on aura
est-ce que les prix vont tenir j'ai déjà
une vine qui est morte je ne sais pas
comment ça va réagir le monde agricole
attend désormais des actes concrets de
la part des politiques en attendant tous
se réjouissent du soutien de la
population couverture chaude croissant
ou encore soupe les dons sont nombreux
je suis venu alors je leur ai amené une
cocotte de soupe pour qu'ils a bien
chaud au ventre pour qu'il puisse tenir
parce que la nuit moi quand je me couche
je me couche au chaud et je pense à eux
qui sont là dehors avec les températures
en PU que nous avons c'est pas l'été et
c'est pas le Club Med avec des réserves
de nourriture de 3 semaines les
agriculteurs ont annoncé poursuivre la
mobilisation le temps qu'il faudra un
boycot et un blocage du Salon
international de l'agriculture sont même
envisagé à Paris en février prochain si
aucune mesure n'est prise d'ici là voilà
la hausse des charges les difficultés à
respecter les normes les malades dit qui
décime le bétail les raisons de la
colère du monde agricole sont multiples
mais la rémunération de leur travail
reste le point central de leur
préoccupation 5 ans après la loi égalim
qui devait rémunérer les agriculteurs en
fonction de leur coût de production les
syndicats agricool de la
FDSEA et des jeunes agriculteurs 42 ont
empêché la sortie des camions sur le
site de Lactalis c'est un reportage
d'Anthony verpillon pour TL7 dans la
Loire après les panneaux retournés le
slogan marche sur la tête était de
nouveau de sortie devant Lactalis à
andrésieux car l'exaspération repart de
plus belle 5 ans après la loi égalim qui
devait rémunérer les agriculteurs en
fonction de leur coût de production
autour de 45 centimes d'euros le litre
en montagne c'est en pleine ça irait
bien en montagne on est nous sommes
plutôt à 50 centimes aujourd'hui
Lactalis pour au cité est à 40,5
centimes donc vous allez me dire c'est
que l'histoire de 4 5 centimes mais
c'est énorme un agriculteur dans la
Loire livre à peu près 250000 L de lait
en moyenne ça représente 10000 € à la
fin de l'année et c'est de la marge
nette c'est presque c'est son c'est son
revenu quoi malheureusement et s'il
manque 4 à 5 centimes pour arriver au
coût de production chez les éleveurs
estampillers Lactalis le manque à gagné
n'est que d'un centime chez le
concurrent SODIAL qui travaille avec 75
% des exploitations nigériennes un prix
qui fluctue en permanence pour des ur
tenu par les contrats àite passés avec
les préleveurs je suis pas sûr que
l'herbe soit forcément plus verte
ailleurs mais à un moment donné nous on
veut juste qu'il a vraiment une une une
cohérence et qu'on soit vraiment pris en
considération c'est du local c'est des
gens du département qui travaillent donc
je veux dire après peu importe
entreprise dans laquelle on est c'est
juste qu'il nous paye en fonction de
notre coût de production pour qu'on
puisse vivre digement de notre métier et
dans un contexte mondial instable qui
les percute de plein fois les
agriculteurs en ont assz d'être la
variable d'ajustement du pouvoir d'achat
des ménages sous le prétexte de la de du
pouvoir d'achat et de l'inflation il
m'attraque les produits alimentaires il
faut à tout prix que les produits
alimentaires soient le moins cher
possible alors que je prends toujours
cet exemple quand on achète un téléphone
portable à 1500 € ça choque personne il
y a rien qui est frit en France par
contre quand on quand on augmente le
litre de lait de 10 centimes d'euros et
c'est ce qui sauverait la la filière
laitière de 10 centimes d'euros tout
tout le monde en parle négociation avec
les industriells devrait encore durer 15
jours pour arriver enfin à un prix
d'équilibre autre chose dans l'actualité
500 bateaux de pêche sont immobilisés
depuis le début de la semaine et pour un
mois entre le Pays-Basque et le
finisterère pour assurer la protection
des dauphins le résultat d'un long
combat des associations de protection de
l'environnement contre les captures
accidentelles de ces cacé dans leur
filet 15 bateaux se retrouvent ainsi
bloqués sur le port d'Arcachon Alix
Fourcade et Julie
était sur place pour TV7 la chaîne du
groupe
sud-ouest sur le port d'Arcachon ce
lundi matin difficile d'échanger avec
les pêcheurs tant la colère les laissit
s'ans voie il votent des trucs ou il
décident de trucs en fin d'année quand
les bateaux sont arrêtés
quand tu commences ton année tu te
prends ça dans la tronche je sais pas
quoi on nous a parlé de subvention
peut-être mais on veut pas vivre de
subvenion on veut travailler c'est tout
jusqu'au 20 février inclu la pêche dans
le golfe de Gascogne est interdite au de
plus de 8 m équipé d'un certain type de
filet près de 500 bateaux français sont
concernés entre la Bretagne et le Pays
Basque à Arcachon sur les 20
embarcations présentes 15 ne doivent pas
quitter le port on leur demande de
réduire leur capture et c'est ce qu'ils
font on leur demande d'adapter leur
matériel c'est ce qu'ils font depuis des
années mais aujourd'hui effectivement
c'est un peu la la goutte d'eau qui fait
des B d'Evas ils sont résignés ils ont
du mal aussi à se projeter dans un
avenir à court terme on espère ne pas
hypothéquer aussi notre activité pour la
reprise parce qu'une fois que les flux
auront été mis en place des ports
notamment du Nord Danemark Norvège
Royaume-Uni et bien c'est aussi de la
concurrence pour nous donc quand ça va
reprendre à la réouverture il faut aussi
qu'on trouve un déboucher pour nos
produits voilà c'est donc toute une
filière qui ne sait pas sur quel pied
danser ce poissonnier se fournit
habituellement en majorité à la criée
d'Arcachon on pense que l'interdicction
va impacter les pr mais après c'est
l'offre et la demande et en période de
février il y a pas non plus une une
demande importante donc il va y avoir un
impact mais pas non plus énorme en fait
affaire à suivre donc rappelons que
cette décision a été prise par le
Conseil d'État pour limiter les captures
accidentelles de dauphin dans le golfe
de Gascogne entre décembre et avril 2022
l'Observatoire péagist a recensé 1380
échouages de petit céacés sur le
littoral atlantique
avec l'augmentation de la température de
l'eau de 0,4°gr en moyenne tous les 10
ans la Méditerranée devient un lieu
propice au développement des espèces
tropicales même à cette époque de
l'année les pêcheurs remontent trop
souvent des barracouas vous avez bien
entendu ce qui n'est pas très bon signe
pour l'avenir de la Méditerranée pour la
Provence regardez ce reportage de Rudy
daran Gérard est l'un des pêcheurs
plongeurs historiques de la siota un
véritable témoin et acteur de
l'évolution sousmar au quen il a
constaté comme beaucoup le retour en
force des barracoua le long des côtes de
la région les biomasses de Barracuda ell
cesse
d'augmenter pas spécialement que la ch
on a des témoignages de de de Copin
ailleurs aussi et c'est vrai que son des
poissons qui affectionnent les zones
portuaires euh surtout quand elles sont
aérées et grandes comme comme la nôtre
et le plus important c'est la qualité de
l'eau si la la qualité de l'eau est
bonne les Baras ils viennent s'installer
dans dans le port aujourd'hui dans les
population de Barra on a des des des des
des spécimenses qui commencent à
ressembler au Barracuda de du du
Pacifique un bon signe donc pour la vie
sous-marine qui témoigne d'une eau
particulièrement saine mais cela peut
aussi inquiéter car le réchauffement
climatique n'est pas pour rien dans
cette mutation du milieu aquatique c'est
un des effets du réchauffement
climatique après on peut avoir un effet
pervers comme celui qu'on a eu en 2022
c'est-à-dire la méga mortalité
de des Gorgones duû à une période de
chaleur trop importante et surtout trop
longtemps et nous on est vigilant on est
des lanceurs d'alerte pourquoi parce que
on est un
dérouateur 200 jours par an et c'est
pour ça que l'agence deau nous attribué
ce rôle parce qu' ils sont àides de de
constat qui soit positif ou négatif la
siota on a on a une très très belle zone
autour de l'île vert une faunne marine
qui se reconstitue le résultat en partie
donc d'une eau de plus en plus saine
d'ailleurs ce matin-là un ban de dauphin
est venu saluer notre équipe à quelques
mètres du bord comme un témoignage de la
nature qui reprend peu à peu ses droits
sur son
milieu connaître la qualité de l'air
extérieure dans notre environnement et
rentrer dans nos habitudes comme
d'autres villes en France l'imoge va
plus loin en participant à ce projet de
laadème qui vise à mesurer la qualité de
l'air dans les espaces clos que sont les
salles de classe par exemple 16 classes
de qure groupes scolaires participent à
cette étude regardez ce reportage
d'Alain druau pour cette
halimoge la qualité de l'air est une
composante des bulletins météo ces
données suivent généralement cell du
temps la ville de Limoge va plus loin
dans un projet de l'ADEM actter qui
subventionne à 70 % le coût de l'étude
de la qualité de l'air dans les salles
de classe 16 classes sont concernées et
équipées de capteurs dans quatre groupes
scolaires il existe une réglementation
où on suit quelques polluants quelques
composés organiques volatiles mais la
ville de limoche qui s'est lancé en
particulier sur la lutte contre les
perturbateurs endocriniens on a souhaité
compléter ce panel avec toute un volet
de polluant que ça soit les particules
fines l'ozone le radon mais aussi des
polluants comme les moisissures on a
voulu suivre aussi d'autres paramètres
de confort température humidité le bruit
aussi on doit considérer que tout ce qui
entre dans une classe est un polluant en
premier l'air externe la respiration des
occupants mais du sol au plafond tout
entre en ligne de compte il y a des
modifications profondes d'une part du
cahier des charge des constructions mais
aussi de façon peut-être plus
pragmatique au
quotidien des
adaptations du mobilier des systèmes de
nettoyage du système de ventilation dans
nos différentes écoles avec la campagne
de mesure et d'exploitation des données
des actions d'information sont menées à
l'école auprès des enfants ils savent
quand même beaucoup de choses euh les
fleurs par exemple c'est quelque chose
que souvent je me dis ils vont pas y
penser que ça pollue et au final ils y
ont pensé assez rapidement et ils savent
quand même beaucoup de choses les
aérosols ils le savent donc c'est vrai
qu'ils connaissent vraiment pas mal de
choses désormais des tablettes
permettent de suivre l'état de l'air en
temps réel dans ses classes on le voit
restons dans la problématique de
l'environnement avec cette initiative
originale à Pont de clé dans
l'aglomération de Grenoble je vous
propose de découvrir une entreprise qui
développe des innovations pour accélérer
le processus de réhabilitation des
friches contaminées pour ses recherches
l'entreprise C d'escargot et de verre de
terre qu'elle met en contact avec le sol
pollué regardez ce reportage de notre
partenaire sur place télé grrenoble à
Pont de clé chez Crisalide escargot et
verre de terre collaborent pour analyser
des sols pollués ils vont brouter de
l'herbe ils vont manger de la terre ils
vont inaller les poussières ils vont
inaller les gaz du sol pour savoir si
les polluant en place impactent leur
santé et également si il se transfère à
ses organismes un sol est considéré
comme dégradé par la présence de
produits qui ne s'y trouent pas
naturellement et que cette dégradation
crée des risques pour la santé et pour
l'environnement l'objectif de la société
est de trouver des innovations pour
dépolluer et réhabiliter des friches les
friches sont contaminées en lien avec
des activités passées notamment
industrielles et sur sur des décennies
et des décennies d'activités
industrielles et bien il y a de la la
pollution qui un filtre peu à peu dans
les sols et peu à peu dans les nappes et
qui crée à terme finalement une
contamination non négligeable des sols
contaminés peuvent causer des mauxs de
tête des nausées ou encore des blocages
neuromusculaires il y a des effets
divers et variés sur la santé chez
l'homme mais aussi sur le vivant donc si
nous ça qui nous intéresse aussi
l'environnement et donc là l'idée ça va
être d'exposer des escargots donc là
j'en ai 15 et donc là ils vont être
laissés pendant 28 jours
à pouvoir être en contact avec le sol et
on sait qu' ils vont absorber
contaminant donc tac tac tac donc l'idée
c'est après exposition de leur faire une
prise de sang pour connaître leur état
de santé et pour ça on fait un petit
trou dans la
coquille et on va piquer dans le cœur et
il y a du sang qui coule c'est une
technique qui estét qui est non invasive
dans le sens où il va réussir après à
reconstruire sa coquille en 7 jours
contaminer les sols l'un des traitements
efficaces est l'utilisation de
champignons donc le champignon va
sécréter des enzymes qui vont permettre
de dégrader le polluant qui est
compliqué à décomposer en molécules plus
simples et et donc l'objectif au final
c'est d'essayer d'avoir des molécules
qui sont plus inoffensive 100 acteurs
public et privés gravitent autour de
Crisalide à la fin de l'année la société
va passer à une recherche sur la
contamination auè fluoré dit aussi
polluant
éternel désormais à Flic secours le prix
du repas proposé à la cantine repose sur
les revenus des ménages les écoles
publiques de ce village de la Somme
propose depuis peu la cantine à 1 €.
pour le maire de la commune cette
cantine à 1 € est une réponse cohérente
aux difficultés financière de certaines
familles qui parfois hésitent à mettre
leur tête blonde à la cantine un
reportage de Jérôme Oubron pour notre
partenaire o TV la chaîne de la voie du
Nord 12h l'heure de recharger les
batteries pour les élèves de cette école
de flic secours au menu de ce repas
végétarien fait maison c'est pomm et
l'os rose ensuite on a steak de soja
basilic tomate avec une fondue de
poireau et pommes de terre et en dessert
un kaki un repas qui il y a peu coûtait
encore 2,50 € aux familles mais depuis
le 1er janvier dernier le prix des repas
est adapté au revenus des ménages de 50
centimes pour les parents les plus
modestes à 3 € pour les plus aisés une
tarification basée sur le con familial
qui ne met pas tout le monde d'accord
moi pas très contente parce que
forcément je travaille mon mari
travaille donc pour nous c'est une
augmentation on passe à 3 € le ticket
alors qu'on a pas le choix de mettre
notre enfant à la cantine quoi alors je
pense que c'est une bonne chose pour
certaines familles ça peut permettre à
certains enfants d'avoir au moins un bon
repas par jour complet surtout si ça
descend vraiment à 50 centimes pour
d'autres permettre de lutter contre la
précarité alimentaire au sein des écoles
publiques c'est tout l'enjeu de la
cantine à 1 €. lancé en 2019 le
dispositif incite les communes
volontaires à proposer un tarif adapté
d'un € maximum par jour en contrepartie
l'état compense la perte engendrée pour
le maire de flic secours c'est surtout
une réponse logique à un besoin il y
avait beaucoup d'impayés notamment de
gens qui n'arrivaient vraiment plus à
payer qui et on voulait que les enfants
mangent quand même quoi parce que la
solution c'est pas de leur interdire la
cantine surtout pas avant c'était 250
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a des parents
qui hésitent à mettre leurs enfants à la
cantine parce que 250 par4 ça faisait 10
€ par semaine et donc au bout de 6
semaines voilà ça fait quand même une
somme qui pour eux est très cher pour
l'heure sur les 90 familles ayant
renseigné leur cotient familial 46
bénéficiaires du dispositif ont été
identifiés créé il y a 11 ans cette
entreprise de confection de jeans tissé
dans les vuges propose une nouvelle
gamme écologique de pantalons 100 % made
in France à base de coton français et de
de Nimes recyclé pour VOG TV je vous
propose d'accompagner Ana isgal et Anne
Didier qui visitent cette entreprise
regardez donc le tissus un mélange de
fil blanc et de fil bleu un fil
naturellement clair pour un jean à la
mode délavé pourtant dans cette nouvelle
gamme proposée par la marque 1083 aucun
processus chimique n'entre en compte ce
dénim tissé à rue sur Moselle est le
résultat d'un mariage réussi entre du
coton cultivé en France et de vieux
jeans se recycler au niveau écologique
c'est très intéressant parce que ce jean
aim C fois moins d'impact carbone donc
au lieu de d'émettre 32 kg carbone avec
un jean conventionnel là ce jean là
n'aimit que 6 kg carbone un déim
nettement moins gourmand en eau
également comptez en effet 160 L d'eau
pour la confection d'un jean de cette
gamme contre 3200 l en moyenne pour un
modèle concurrent ce tissu est également
100 % français puisque depuis 2022
l'entreprise cultive son propre coton
sur 3 hactares de plantation dans la
Drome et dans le gerse récolté l'année
dernière puis filé dans le nord de la
France il est tissé pour la première
fois dans les vauges une culture au
rendement plutôt faible malgré tout car
le coton s'épanouit d'habitude sous des
latitudes plus chaudes on est tellement
un pays surproducteur de textile qu'on
en jette beaucoup et cette ce déchet on
a développé une stratégie pour en faire
une matière première et c'est ce coton
issu du recyclage qu'on mélange à notre
coton cultivé en France pour doubler les
rendements de no chon de coton et
pouvoir proposer un jeans 100 % en coton
français avec 600 kg de coton récolté et
autant de tissus recyclés cette première
salle veut permettre perettra de tisser
1500 jeans qui seront proposés à la
vente d'ici mars 2024 cette gamme là on
la démarre on sait pas trop quelle poids
elle va prendre dans notre collection
mais c'est déjà 3 % en 2023 2024 donc
c'est pour un projet de RD c'est
beaucoup et puis ensuite c'est les
consommateurs qui vont faire un petit
peu le le poids de cette gamme dans
notre offre prochain objectif désormais
élargir encore davantage cette offre
avec la plantation de nouveaux champs de
coton dans la Drome rappelons que 1083
ce sont 50000 jeans vendus chacque année
et 250 emplois directs et indirects dont
une cinquantaine dans les vauges pour
une pièce comptée en moyenne 130 € et
jusqu'à 169 € pour la gamme 100 % mdine
France direction la Mayenne à présent où
se déroule l'un des plus gros chantiers
ferroviaires de la région la ligne de
fret entre châteaugontier sur maenne et
sabl sur Sart est en cours de rénovation
sur cette ligne pas de voyageurs
seulement des marchandises un enjeu
économiquement important pour tout un
territoire et un symbole vol aussi celui
de la renaissance du fret ferroviaire
très longtemps délaissé Enzo mobert pour
LMTV
Sart depuis septembre plus aucun train à
l'horizon les ouvriers sont à pied
d'œuvre pour remplacer 68 km de rail sur
cette ligne classée en fin de vie par la
SNCF on était sur des traverses
métalliques de 1910 et des rails de 1913
donc si rien n'était fait globalement la
ligne on ne savait plus l'entretenir et
le trafic fret n'aurait pas pu perdurer
sur ces ligne là un chantier colossal
entre châteaugontier en Mayenne et Sablé
sur Sart l'une des dernière ligne de
marchandise en exploitation dans la
région on va engager près de 34 millions
d'euros sur sur la rénovation de cette
ligne et la pérénisé pour plusieurs
dizaines d'années un investissement
surprenant pour une ligne où ne circule
que deux trains par semaine mais ici le
fr trouve ses clients comme ce chef
d'entreprise il se fait ses matériaux
par wagon et il a même décidé d'aller
encore plus loin avec la construction
d'un entrepôt au pied de la ligne la
rénovation de la ligne de frite apporte
à une société comme la nôtre la garantie
de pouvoir utiliser le frite ferroviaire
pour ses approvisionnements durant de
nombreuses décennies ce qui est
absolument vital puisque le le le
transport de produits sidérurgiques
çaacommode très bien le transport
ferroviaire pour des raisons
environnemental pour des raisons de
productivité un atout pourtant peu
utilisé par les entreprises le fret ne
représente que 3 % des marchandises
transportées en Pays de la Loire la SNCF
et la région ont pour objectif de
doubler 7 part d'ici 2030 l'enjeu il est
bien clair c'est massifier les flux euh
faire du transbordement c'est-à-dire sur
le travail à longue distance de pouvoir
aujourd'hui utiliser plus des outils
massifiés comme le train et après
décarboné décarboné c'est ce qu'on a mis
en place depuis maintenant plus de 10
ans avec le biognv pour faire en sorte
que désormais même le dernier kilomètre
soit totalement décarboné déc carboné
oui encore faut-il des locomotives
électriques ce qui n'est pas le cas sur
cette
ligne autorisé en France depuis
seulement 3 ans le MMA est en plein
essort et cela se ressent dans les
associations d'arts martiaux elle croule
sous les demandes de nouveaux adhérents
désireux de s'essayer au MMA certaines
mettent en place des courses spécifiques
regardez pour via Occitanie Antoine
Guillet nous emmène dans un club au cœur
de nîes à la découverte de ces cours
multi
disciplinaire allez c'est parti un
maximum de submission en une minute
rapide
rapide comme chaque lundi c'est jujitsu
brésilien au fighting club nimois ISAM
betaya n'enseigne pas de MMA mais
plusieurs disciplines utile au
combattants dans la pratique des ARS
martiaux mixtes on a préféré faire lundi
là comme ce soir ben c'est juste
brésilien demain sera kickboxing et
vendredi ça sera grappling MMA
mais voilà le un seul cours de MMA pour
nous on a bien on avait vu on avait fait
cette expérience là que
ça c'était pas on n'arrivait pas à
mettre en place tout l'aspect technico-
tactique l'enseignement la pédagogie
nombreux sont les jeunes combattants à
se tourner vers le MMA et si les clubs
spécialisés sont rares ils se retrouent
dans l'apprentissage de sport de combat
composant direct du MMA à la base je
voulais faire du MMA mais j'ai découvert
le jugitu qui me passionne énormément
aussi et bien sûr je suis satisfait
parce que che charme en plus c'est
complet donc on fait du prier point on
fait du sol le Jujitsu brésilien permet
au combattants de travailler le sol à la
différence du MMA les jujitsukka portent
des kimono les prises et les techniques
ne sont donc pas les mêmes mais
certaines passerelles existent entre les
deux sports je sors de la Garde
ouverture de garde passage de garde je
prends une position dominante là là le
travail c'est le travail de celui qui
est dans la garde voilà là le travail ça
va être celui-là de passer la garde bon
là il y a pas les frappes parce que on
n'est pas en MMA mais euh si on serait
en MMA ce serait la même chose la
pratique est en plein essort légalisé en
France en 2020 on estime aujourd'hui à
60000 le nombre de combattants soit
autant que pour la boxe anglaise un
nombre qui ne devrait pas faiblir les
organisateurs de combat s'arrache de
plus en plus les salles françaises et
leurs combattants voilà et puis cette
semaine je vous signale la sortie du
nouveau numéro du magazine Le Point
spécial nî intitulé nî la Renaissance la
ville qui mise sur ses entreprises
qualifies de pépit avec aussi la
création de 2 à 3000 emplois à
l'aéroport enfin en matière d'art ce
sont les coups de cœur de Sophie roule à
l'exposition Claude Viala et enfin le
festival de la biographie avec le choix
des libraires c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition du Grand JIT des territoires au
revoir à tous
[Musique]